France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bienvenue pour ici l'Europe afin de
recevoir notre grande invité de la
semaine et pour cela nous prenons la
direction de Tallinn en Estonie ce petit
pays baltes d'un million 300000
habitants Aix république soviétique a
adhéré à l'Union européenne il y a
presque 20 ans et a toujours été très
inquiet des agissements de son grand
voisin il a alerté ses partenaires
européens sur le caractère
expansionniste du régime de Vladimir
Poutine et préconise depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine la
plus grande fermeté nous recevons
aujourd'hui kerstical oujay bonjour je
rappelle que vous êtes l'ancienne
présidente d'Estonie entre 2016 et 2021
vous étiez la première femme à ce poste
et vous pourriez aussi d'ailleurs être
la première à prendre la tête de l'OTAN
la lance Atlantique à laquelle votre
pays a adhéré en 2004 comme dix anciens
pays communistes d'ailleurs car le
mandat de yenstockenberg secrétaire
général de l'OTAN se termine le premier
octobre des noms de femmes surtout
circulent le vôtre avec un distance vous
êtes intéressé par ce job
moi je sais pas spéculaire ces questions
succession de instant
timbergate secrétaire général magnifique
pour le temps pendant le dernier 10 ans
on peut dire presque
il a toujours trouvé les meilleurs
moyens de
renforcer la position de l'OTAN aussi
toute près de la Russie en courant que
toutes les robes connues est compris ce
qui est vraiment le régime de Vladimir
Poutine il n'a pas eu de ressources il a
créé après l'occupation de la Crimée
c'était magnifique nous sommes vraiment
enchantés que nous avons eu une
secrétaire général dans ces périodes
assez difficiles il faut dire pour
l'Europe en général l'Europe de l'ESTA
en particulier mais qui ont renforcé
l'OTAN avec la volonté d'adhérer de la
Finlande et de la Suède même si la Suède
est encore très bloquée notamment par la
Russie et la Hongrie ça ça vous inquiète
que finalement il y a des blocages dans
ces additions
oui moi je trouve que nos proches
communes maintenant on a l'automne et
juste ignorer que il y a une blocage sur
la question de la Suède par exemple tous
les pays Nord ont déjà décidé de réunir
leur force aérienne avant que la Suède
peuvent finalement joindre le temps donc
tout le monde fait comme ils sont déjà
là et je suis sûr que cette c'est une
approche qui va donner un résultat
positif finalement aussi pour la Suède
et bien sûr nous sommes très heureuses
que la femme déjà
alors les 13 précédents secrétaires
généraux de l'OTAN ça vous a pas échappé
était tous des hommes et de l'Ouest en
plus ça changerait quoi une femme
issue finalement de l'Est de l'Europe
je suis sûr que toute la femme des
présidents anciens présidents ensemble
première ministre première ministre
d'aujourd'hui aussi on se prête à servir
le temps parce que l'automne c'est une
organisme très très important pour nous
tous et aussi
les
relations entre louer et l'OTAN ont très
très importante renforcée
particulièrement pendant cette crise
donc c'est une période développement
intéressante et nous sommes tous
bien sûr prête à servir
Président vous vous en particulier en
tout cas on l'entend vous vous avez
rencontré en tant que première en tant
que présidente pardon Vladimir Poutine
en 2019 qu'elle avait été votre
impression à l'époque j'ai visité Moscou
par exemple que tout mon voyage est
partenaire
entre aussi les relations parlant avec
la Russie tout le monde parle avec la
Russie et moi j'ai reçu beaucoup de
comment que qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
dire en Vladimir Poutine parce que tout
le monde sauf que il
ne compte pas
le président des pays baltes et manger
décidé de changer ça moi je peux parler
avec lui moi-même genre
des autres présidents de l'Europe pour
avoir ces discussions c'est difficile
nous avons discuté le crâne nous avons
discuté la Géorgie mais aussi nous avons
en discuté la technique des deux pays
voisins nous avons eu beaucoup de
discuter sur les routes sur la rail les
questions qui tournent pays voisins en
fait prendre le
frappé nous avons encore parlé par le
téléphone parce qu'il faut informer que
nous avons fermé le
fermer notre
notre pays pour
les Russes pour pour le passage pendant
covid c'était le risque de contamination
qui enfermé tous les pays ont fermé
parmi parmi nous aussi c'est juste un
accent que il faut parler avec une
voisin mais maintenant comme il a dit
c'était en conférence
Emmanuel Macron a dit que bien sûr il
faut avoir une discussion en ce moment
il n'y a personne avec qui nous pouvons
discuter ça a changé malheureusement ce
n'était pas encore il y a 4 ans
maintenant oui aujourd'hui on peut plus
vraiment discuter selon vous avec Moscou
ni avec d'ailleurs ce régime vous vous
dites que les relations de l'Occident
avec la Russie ne peuvent revenir à la
normale tant qu'il ne se régit n'a pas
changé que le responsable de génocide
doivent payer et même la situation de la
transmission et de la Géorgie doivent
être mises sur la table c'est pas un peu
ambitieux on peut comparer ça peut-être
en Allemagne après la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'était l'Allemagne qui a
changé qui a traité c'est qu'ils sont
faites pour qu'ils sont faites en Europe
la clim d'agression ils sont cette face
à toute ça donc pour moi la Russie a
changé quand tous ces choses on
discutait
aux écoles aux universités dans leur
curricula
en Russie c'est simple que pour moi est
une mesure des changements réel mais ça
commence
ce ne sera pas un changement de régime
et quand le régime a changé bien sûr ils
sont prêtes à discuter de devenir une
paille normale une pays dont peut-être
démocratique en Europe
mais pour l'instant on en est pas là et
d'ailleurs ça suppose que vous dites une
victoire militaire de reconquête de
l'Ukraine est-ce que vous la croyez
possible
les deux ce sont pas les mêmes choses
changements de régime en Russie est
possible bien sûr après après la
victoire de guerre pour l'Ukraine mais
la victoire de guerre pour l'Ukraine
ne fait pas automatiquement en changer
le régime en Russie donc les deux choses
sont clairement séparées pour moi
premièrement il faut gagner la guerre il
faut continuer à supporter le crâne avec
tout ce qu'ils sont
ils se trouvent nécessaire par exemple
support aérien bien sûr c'est si
nécessaire qu'ils sont une opportunité
d'avoir aussi des gens des avions des
pays d'aouest parce que autrement il
lutte tout le temps comme avec une main
seulement
pourquoi pourquoi ça fait durer la
guerre plus longtemps pensant et le
temps pendant Ukraine n'est pas mesuré
par les jours par les mains par le
chemin mais par la vie par la vie perdue
donc donc il faut il faut
raccourcir ses guerres si possible les
pays d'Europe centrale et orientale sont
à l'avant-garde des mesures de la
réponse de la guerre en Ukraine ils sont
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus audible depuis
le déclenchement de la guerre parce
qu'ils ont mis en garde contre Vladimir
Poutine est-ce que le centre de gravité
de l'Europe de l'Union européenne est en
train de se déplacer vers l'Est selon
vous par exemple si on regarde les
questions d'économie les pays du Nord
ont toujours peut-être sur la même page
plus que les plus grands pays de
l'Europe de centre on sait question nous
sommes tous unis ce qui concerne le
crâne et il y a des autres choses que on
a des autres partenaires
qui concerne les matières de l'Europe on
peut pas dire que c'est toujours le même
bloc dans l'Europe moi je trouve ça bien
en fait il y a eu visite surprise cette
semaine du secrétaire général de l'OTAN
il y a une saltenberg sur le seuil
ukrainien sur le sol pardon il s'est
recueilli devant le mémorial des
militaires tués au combat et il a
déclaré le futur de l'Ukraine et dans la
famille euro-atlantique le futur de
l'Ukraine est dans l'OTAN est-ce que par
rapport à une Russie qui craignait qui a
déclenché cette guerre au motif dit-elle
que justement l'Ukraine s'apprêtait à
rejoindre l'OTAN ça n'est pas un peu
provocateur on sait bien que ce
processus prend du temps premièrement
quand il y a la guerre
après sans faire de réformes
troisièmement joindre l'Union européenne
et après ça bien sûr on va avoir ces
questions pourquoi pas l'OTAN moi je
suis sûr que c'est toujours arrive parce
que je suis optimistique donc je peux
joindre vraiment avoir un savant
de son PIB consacré justement
à la défense c'est le seuil évidemment
préconisé par le temps et au début de
l'année la Pologne a annoncé une
augmentation de ses dépenses de défense
avec l'objectif de construire la plus
grande armée d'Europe d'ici 2030 il y a
un impact quand même réel de cette
guerre sur notre stratégie de sécurité
notre architecture de sécurité
bien sûr le dividende des pays c'est
maintenant fini donc il faut bien sûr
produire plus de chars plus dans mon
mission plus
il n'y a pas d'autres opportunités parce
que bien sûr la Russie peuvent changer
mais on ne peut pas après prévenir sans
c'est pas prévu donc il faut faire face
à une risque longue terme une situation
semblante bien sûr le
guerre franc donc ça peut durer ça peut
durer donc il faut être préparé et le
temps devrait être prête à faire face de
risques
et le risque sont en Europe seulement la
Russie
notre gouvernement a décidé de dépenser
3% de notre pays pour la défense
maintenant oui voilà en Estonie en
Lettonie renforcement de la défense
précision dans ces deux pays un tiers de
la population 28% pour vous à le russe
comme langue maternelle et russophone
donc par exemple vous avez interdit le
gouvernement en tout cas interdit au
tourisme avec des visages Schengen
d'entrée sur le territoire ce qui ce qui
finalement ne leur permet pas de d'avoir
des liens de familiaux c'est une crainte
de cette minorité russophone donc ces
russophone et est-ce que ils sont des
citoyens estoniens comme les autres
premièrement les citoyens d'Estonie qui
sont très profonds traité différemment
des autres citoyens
deuxièmement c'est vrai que on a
interdit à pour les citoyen de Rust
entrée Estonie il y a beaucoup qui fait
fuites de mobilisation par exemple qui
cherche
en résidait en Europe
supportant petit mais irritante la
guerre nous ne voulons pas ces gens ici
en Estonie et bien sûr il y a toujours
le risque de provocation parce que on a
beaucoup de monuments ici qui concerne
les mammeries mémorial de deuxième
guerre mondiale aussi les mouvements qui
qui ont
causé beaucoup de discussions et on a vu
2007 par exemple les provocations
des côtés de Russie pour avoir des
perturbantes
en ce qui concerne
comme on pense de deuxième guerre
mondiale ici en Estonie donc c'est une
c'est une lutte stratégique donc dans le
moyen de communication pour la Russie
pour pour
supporter la notion des Rousses qui
mirent le monde de la Russie ici en
Estonie mais il faut dire que 80% de
notre rousse au fond honte contre contre
la guerre en Ukraine les autres n'ont
pas pour mais peut-être un autre
alors en Estonie première femme première
ministre aussi kayak Calas dont le parti
de la réforme a remporté les élections à
finalement décidé de former une
coalition pour travailler avec Estonia
de sang et le Parti social-démocrate une
coalition très attaquée par l'extrême
droite est-ce que d'abord elle va tenir
cette coalition et ce que c'est ces
démocratie qui sont en coalition sont
beaucoup plus fragiles et ça c'est une
un sujet d'inquiétude
la coalition peut être très très fragile
bien sûr parce qu'il y a il y a trois
parties il y a ces différentes en
sexualisation équation mais s'il si ça
casse c'est pas parce que il y a
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite
Estonie en fait tu as perdu beaucoup de
support maintenant parce que pendant les
périodes électorale ils sont ils sont
doutés c'est que l'Estonie fait pour
l'Ukraine est pour les Ukrainiens
réfugiés ici en Estonie et
par exemple côté cher ça me dit que tous
les Estoniens ont unis pour pour
continuer notre politique interne et
externe en ce qui concerne le crème et
les réfugiés
pour terminer justement les 27
s'apprêtent à prendre un 11e pardon
train de sanctions est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de ces sanctions
européennes et ce qu'elles sont
importantes et ce qu'elles fonctionnent
et ce qu'on est en train de modifier
aussi notre stratégie en 2023
si on a déjà des sanctions il faut les
modifier et continuer tout le temps
parce que l'économie est une force
énorme et l'économie s'adapte toujours
et il faut il faut bien sûr vérifier que
les sanctions sont efficaces
fonctionnent toujours donc le changement
donne prévu bien sûr je suis sûr de ça
merci d'avoir été en notre compagnie
madame la Présidente merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis restez avec nous pour
un débat au Parlement européen cette
fois-ci sur la question des eaux et de
l'accès à l'eau dans l'Union européenne
avec des euros d'études
merci de nous rejoindre au Parlement
européen à Bruxelles dans une Europe
déjà assoiffée alors que nous sommes au
mois d'avril à peine selon les experts
de la Commission européenne la
sécheresse de 2022 a été la pire de ses
500 dernières années et les 27 États
membres redoutent déjà l'été 2023 des
restrictions drastiques ont été mises en
place dans certaines régions les plus
sièges au Sud par exemple de la France
au nord de l'Espagne et de l'Italie au
sud de l'Allemagne au nord de la Grèce
et au sud de la Bulgarie 14% des
Européens sont concernés par un stress
hydrique avec le réchauffement
climatique l'or bleu se fait de plus en
plus rare certains projets tentent d'y
remédier sobriété utilisation des eaux
usées ou encore les mégabassines ces
réservoirs d'eau géants qui engendrent
de fortes résistances notamment en
France Bruxelles cherche à assurer notre
approvisionnement en eau et à en
garantir sa qualité allant même jusqu'à
envisager un droit à l'eau potable pour
ses concitoyens mais comment garantir
cette ressource indispensable à notre
survie alors pour en débattre
aujourd'hui 2 euros députés Face à Nous
Benoît Biteau un Français agriculteur et
écologiste on vous a d'ailleurs vu
récemment aux côtés des manifestants
opposés au projet de méga bassines à
Sainte Soline et face à vous une
italienne Laura Ferrara bonjour du
mouvement 5 étoiles qui siège aux côtés
donc des non inscrits Venise sans eau
c'est une réalité en février ça a été le
cas en 2023 au delà du symbole
d'ailleurs ça doit nous alerter mais oui
ça ça s'est vraiment
le contraire de le problème qu'on avait
avant on avait trop d'eau avant donc on
avait la l'inquiétude que voilà tout la
ville pouvait aller sous l'eau et mais
non il n'y a plus d'eau on a le risque
qu'il n'y a judo donc vraiment il y a on
a un alarme très fort voilà qui pousse
depuis longtemps et on devrait vraiment
prendre des des mesures au niveau
européen pour faire face à un problème
que c'est déjà trop tard à réagir
maintenant
en plein hiver une partie de l'Union
européenne est déjà en alerte rouge car
les nappes phréatiques sont à sec c'est
le cas dans le nord de l'Italie c'était
tellement le cas dans le nord de
l'Espagne ça s'améliore légèrement en
France que se passe-t-il il se passe que
on n'a pas créé les conditions dans les
aménagements du territoire et
l'agriculture est centrale d'ailleurs
sur ce sujet là pour que l'eau quand
elle est présente sur nos territoires
soit retenue et la possibilité de
descendre en profondeur pour recharger
les nappes le changement climatique
amplifie le phénomène c'est à dire qu'on
a souvent les mêmes précipitations les
mêmes pluviométries sauf que elles sont
beaucoup moins bien réparties donc des
fortes pluviométries à des instants
donnés et des longues périodes sans
géométrie et donc ça amplifie le
phénomène puisqu'on n'a pas su créer les
infrastructures écologiques pour retenir
cette eau quand elle est présente pour
qu'elle puisse recharger les nappes elle
part trop vite à la mer et donc comme
les épisodes plus vieux sont devenus
trop rares trop espacées et bien entre
deux épisodes plus vieux on n'a pas le
temps de recharger de recharger les
nappes c'est c'est la grande différence
avec il y a quelques décennies où on
avait des régimes pluviométriques plus
fréquents et donc le temps même si l'eau
partait à la mer on avait quand même
suffisamment de d'épisodes plus vieux
pour que l'eau et le temps de recharger
une nappe et donc c'est ça le gros
constat c'est qu'on doit revenir sur des
infrastructures écologiques qui font que
on retient l'eau sur les bassins
versants comment
remet André les cours d'eau c'est à dire
que et je pointe souvent l'agriculture
c'est à dire que le développement
agricole de ces 60 dernières années a
effacer les méandres des cours d'eau à
recalibrer les cours d'eau pour que
l'eau parte beaucoup plus vite à la mer
pour pouvoir rentrer dans les champs on
a retourné les prairies qui étaient des
zones on stocké l'eau quand elle était
excédentaire et parce qu'on l'a stocké
longtemps elle avait le temps de
recharger une nappe avec le
réchauffement climatique on constate en
effet un stress hydrique et une
récurrence des sécheresses dans un
climat pourtant tempéré on se croyait à
l'abri finalement dans dans l'Union
européenne par ce climat tempéré on a
manqué d'anticipation vous trouvez sur
la question de l'eau mais oui mais oui
c'est déjà trop tard comme je disais
avant c'est déjà trop tard parce que on
devait prendre des mesures tout d'abord
pour garantir l'eau à tout le monde
parce que quand on parle d'eau on parle
de la vie et alors on parle d'eau et on
parle d'un droit de l'homme le droit à
avoir l'eau potable pour tout le monde
c'est que aujourd'hui on n'a pas on n'a
pas en Europe mais parfois non même en
Europe on n'a pas de l'eau potable c'est
ça oui parce que quand on ouvre le
robinet à la maison on n'a pas d'eau
potable même en Europe même en Italie
les gens par exemple on a de villes qui
n'ont pas d'eau potable quand on ouvre
le robinet donc ça c'est dramatique ça
c'est vraiment dramatique parce que on
devrait voilà mettre en place des
messieurs pour garantir ce que c'est un
droit de l'homme donc eau potable au ça
veut dire accès au service sanitaire
eugénique voilà c'est l'hygiène c'est la
santé des personnes c'est l'agriculture
comme mon collègue disait j'ai vu qu'on
a aussi une manière de faire
l'agriculture qui va pas dans plusieurs
pays on tente quand même d'apporter des
éléments de réponse avec des plans sur
la gestion de l'eau c'est le cas en
Allemagne c'est le cas en Italie c'est
également le cas en France le président
Emmanuel Macron souhaite que d'ici 2030
on réduise de 10% nos prélèvements en
gros qu'on soit plus dans une sobriété
par rapport à l'utilisation de l'eau
est-ce que Benoit Biteau 1 c'est
suffisant et concrètement comment on
fait
moi je partage l'idée qu'il faut être
plus sobre par rapport à notre
dépendance à l'eau pour les différents
usages d'ailleurs l'agriculture doit
être beaucoup plus sobre en France
l'agriculture c'est la consommation de
50% de la quantité d'eau consommée donc
c'est 50% c'est beaucoup et c'est 80 %
en été où elle est très rare donc c'est
c'est un vrai sujet donc la sobriété est
de rigueur mais ce qu'on peut reprocher
à ce plan c'est qu'on s'attaque pas aux
causes du problème c'est à dire que bien
sûr il faut en consommer moins mais il
faut encore une fois créer toutes les
conditions à fortiori sur la projection
climatique des des prochaines décennies
pour que l'eau qui arrive de là-haut
soit stockés dans de bonnes conditions
c'est-à-dire dans les nappes
souterraines pour qu'elles soient
disponible pour satisfaire tous les
usages et il faut les hiérarchiser
l'usage prioritaire on est d'accord
c'est l'accès à l'eau potable et quand
on parle d'eau potable il y a la
dimension quantitative il en faut
suffisamment mais il faut aussi
travailler sur la qualité c'est à dire
que si on a de l'eau en quantité mais
qu'elle est souillée par des pesticides
ou des engrais de synthèse j'ai ma
fixation sur les sujets agricoles c'est
plus de l'eau potable le deuxième usage
fondamental si on veut satisfaire cette
première priorité d'eau potable c'est le
bon état des milieux aquatiques c'est
les milieux aquatiques qui font que on
va trouver de la ressource disponible
pour satisfaire les usages et si on
prend soin des milieux aquatiques on
pourra satisfaire des usages à vocation
économique le refroidissement des
centrales nucléaires par exemple en
France ou l'agriculture et donc
finalement le chemin il est assez simple
mais ce qu'on peut reprocher au plan de
Monsieur Macron c'est qu'il a tendance à
vouloir trouver des solutions qui
s'attaquent aux conséquences alors qu'il
faut s'attaquer aux causes pour
définitivement régler les problèmes dans
ce plan de gestion justement français
l'un des objectifs c'est de réutiliser
10% des eaux usées en 2030 alors en
Italie alors vous êtes déjà à 15% de
réutilisation des eaux usées qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé exactement mais oui ça
c'est très important dans le système
d'industrie dans le système
d'agriculture même de réutil pour éviter
tout sorte de gaspillage de perte d'eau
que voilà surtout dans ce moment
historique sont très importants on a
créé aussi de
grands bassins d'eau mais ça voilà on a
comme on dit pas tout le monde est
d'accord sur ça parce que même si c'est
une solution qui permet de stocker de
l'eau voilà c'est vrai aussi que n'est
pas pour tout le monde n'est pas pour
les agriculteurs plus petits moyens mais
c'est surtout pour les agriculteurs plus
grands qui fait du gros business donc
sur ça aussi voilà on a des débats alors
justement Benoit j'imagine que vous avez
des choses à dire sur sur ces réserves
d'eau en vous avez manifesté votre
opposition méga mastine c'est réservoirs
d'eau constitué en puisant dans les
nappes phréatiques ou les cours d'eau
durant l'hiver en prévision de l'été
pour une utilisation agricole Emmanuel
Macron dans son plan de gestion de l'eau
les âmes à nouveau légitimées pourquoi
c'est une aberration magique selon vous
c'est d'abord une aboration écologique à
non plutôt avant d'être une aberration
écologique il faut quand même rappeler
ce qui se passe c'est à dire que là et
ça rejoint complètement ce que vient de
dire ma collègue c'est que ça s'adresse
qu'à 6% des agriculteurs seul 6% des
agriculteurs ont accès à l'eau
d'irrigation en France donc ça veut dire
quand monsieur le ministre de la culture
ou même monsieur Macron dit que la
souveraineté alimentaire passe par
l'accès à l'eau c'est parfaitement
insultant méprisant pour les
agriculteurs les 94 autres pour cent qui
continuent de produire en agriculture et
qui eux doivent avec beaucoup de
créativité travailler la fertilité des
sols travailler des infrastructures
agroécologiques pour que l'eau qui tombe
de la pluie soit bien valorisée par leur
production cela sont intéressants mais
sont oubliés du plan Macron c'est à dire
qu'il ne focalise son attention que sur
les 6% de la culture ensuite les méga
bassines on est on assiste à une
privatisation d'une ressource
c'est-à-dire que on fait des trous sur
une parcelle de de 10 à 16 hectares
c'est pour vous donner un peu la
dimension 7 mètres de profondeur 8
mètres de profondeur 7 et 8 mètres de
digue on tend une bâche au fond on fait
un forage et on sort de l'eau
souterraine qui est souvent de très
bonne qualité à température acceptable
pour les mettre dans des réservoirs où
elle va se réchauffer ou la qualité va
se dégrader et à partir du moment où on
la sortie du sous-sol c'est plus un
commun ça devient un bien privé parce
que stocké dans un équipement privé
financer financé par 70 % d'argent
public c'est-à-dire que là il y a un
autre scandale derrière la privatisation
de cette eau c'est qu'on met beaucoup
d'argent public sur la table pour
seulement je répète 6% des agriculteurs
est-ce que vous avez ce genre de de
discussion aussi de débat autour des
méga Abbassides en Italie mais bon on a
oui on a ces débats autour de méga
bassine et on a aussi un débat sur tous
les terrains de petites et moyennes
agriculteurs mais surtout petite qui
n'ont pas accès à l'eau donc il paie
c'est qu'on appelle le je sais pas en
français
c'est à dire c'est comme une association
qui devrait voilà garantir l'accès à
l'eau aux entrepreneurs et aux petites
agriculteurs mais en fait il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas d'eau il n'y a pas de
système de délégation donc oui on a un
très grand débat sur ça on devrait
prendre des mesures pour ne laisser pas
voilà à côté la plus la plus grande
partie parce qu'en fait on a beaucoup
beaucoup surtout au sud d'Italie on a
beaucoup de petits et moyens
d'exploitation agricoles Benoît Biteau
je voudrais revenir sur l'utilisation
des eaux usées en France on est très
mauvais élève à peine 1% de
d'utilisation des eaux usées en Italie
madame Ferrara nous l'a dit on est
autour de 15% pourquoi en France on a
pris un tel retard
est-ce que vouloir absolument remettre
de l'eau usée dans le circuit c'est
toujours la bonne réponse c'est une
vraie question c'est à dire qu'on parle
du cycle de l'eau on parle du grand
cycle de l'eau qu'on connaît tous on
parle du petit cycle de l'eau qui
justement vise à valoriser des eaux
usées dans certaines situations par
exemple utiliser de l'eau de la douche
qu'on a pris pour évacuer
dans les toilettes
nos fesses pourquoi pas c'est une
réutilisation de l'eau en revanche sur
la réutilisation de l'eau dans le grand
cycle de l'eau c'est à dire on a des
zones qui sortent des stations
d'épuration on voit les utiliser en
agriculture ça veut dire qu'au moment où
l'eau est le plus rare donc en été par
exemple au moment où on a besoin de
l'irrigation c'est eau qui réalimente le
système naturel du cycle de l'eau va
disparaître pour être dirigé vers
l'agriculture et donc risque d'aggraver
les difficultés de graves sécheresse de
réalimentation de l'eau au moment où
justement elle est très très rare en été
au moment où l'agriculture irrigue donc
c'est sûrement une bonne solution sur
l'usage ménager on va dire il faut il
faut qu'on avance sur la réutilisation
de l'eau sur des usages ménagers c'est
une très très bonne idée mais attention
à ne pas retirer de l'eau en quantité
importante au moment où elle est très
rare et où les milieux en ont besoin et
en l'occurrence les eaux usées sont de
l'eau qu'on restitue en été au milieu
qui peuvent en avoir besoin alors
l'Union européenne tente de faire passer
des directives pour garantir le droit à
l'eau et surtout le droit à l'eau
potable aussi pour l'ensemble de ces 450
millions de citoyens sachant que 14% des
Européens se trouvent en situation de
stress hydrique est-ce que la Commission
réagit assez vite et assez fort selon
vous bon pas assez vite franchement
parce que je me rappelle dans les 2012
que il y a eu une initiative de citoyens
européens
que voilà avait demandé à la Commission
européenne de d'avoir le droit à l'eau
potable rights to water était voilà
communication qui était promotrice de
cette initiative mais en fait la
commission il y a 10 ans a dit oui on
fera on verra etc tout dans le futur
comme s'il n'était pas une urgence et il
n'était pas une priorité et on est
arrivé voilà exactement 10 ans après
qu'on est en retard donc non je crois
que la Commission européenne pouvait
faire beaucoup plus et beaucoup plus
vite et qu'il faut aller plus vite le
pacte vert vise à réduire la pollution
de l'eau avec des obligations de
traitement des eaux y compris pour les
plus petites communes mais aussi une
protection des eaux de surfaces et
souterraines contre les pollueurs et là
il s'agit bien de la qualité de l'eau
Benoit bitaud on va devoir révolutionner
les habitudes agricoles et industrielles
pour garantir leur bleu il faut
s'attaquer aux causes il faut s'attaquer
aux côtes c'est-à-dire que quand on
constate des pollutions quand on
constate des excès de consommation qui
créent des déséquilibres et qui ne
permet plus de satisfaire les priorités
dont j'ai donné tout à l'heure
stable les milieux aquatiques et ensuite
le économique il faut s'attaquer aux
causes et donc si on veut plus trouver
de pesticides si on veut plus trouver
d'engrais de synthèse dans dans l'eau il
va falloir qu'on effectivement revisite
les pratiques agricoles et le meilleur
moyen et industriel bien entendu il faut
pas il faut pas les oublier mais je
pense à une politique publique majeure
qui est la politique agricole commune
c'est cet outil là qui doit accompagner
les agriculteurs vers la sortie de vers
la sortie des pesticides et des engrais
de synthèse par exemple pour éviter que
l'eau soit polluée et quand on voit
comme à quel point c'est efficace
d'attraper les choses en amont aux
causes plutôt que de s'attaquer aux
conséquences et je prends toujours
l'exemple de la ville de Munich où il y
a 25 ans parce qu'ils avaient une
pollution de leur périmètre de captage
qui était important ils ont décidé de
d'accompagner tous les agriculteurs pour
qu'ils pratiquent l'agriculture
biologique et qu'aujourd'hui le mètre
cube qui sort du périmètre de captage de
mini coûte 1 centime d'euro alors qu'en
Bretagne par exemple pour dépolluer
l'eau qui est souillé avec des
pesticides et des nitrates coûte 27
centimes le rapport c'est 27 fois ça
coûte 27 fois plus cher de porter des
solutions curatives avec l'argent public
de nos impôts que de s'attaquer aux
causes et donc accompagnons
des le début donc attaquons-nous au
causes accompagnons les transitions pour
que enfin ce sujet de l'eau sur fond de
changement climatique soit attrapé par
le bambou merci à tous les deux d'avoir
illustré de façon très pédagogique
finalement ces questions de l'eau qui
sont évidemment vitales vous l'avez bien
souligné merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis vous restez sur nos antennes pour
la suite des programmes merci à vous
[Musique]